here with more former white house
physician who called for joe biden to
take a cognitive test
congressman ronnie jackson he was the
white house physician for both
president obama and president trump
along with california congressman devin
nunes
doctor congressman let me start with you
and and talk about the cognitive side of
things donald trump took
that cognitive test you told me
that he passed it with a perfect score
30 of 30.
you told me it's a hard exam you told me
that you want joe biden to take one
what has been the response
none i haven't heard a single thing sean
and you're right this is not a laughing
matter anymore
i've been saying this ever since he was
candidate candidate biden
and uh you know we we have to know
what's going on at this particular point
it said what about your hypocrites you
showed on tv we had the the far left
the the liberal mainstream media all the
self-appointed
elites in academic medicine demanding
demanding
that president trump have a cognitive
test just because they didn't like the
nature of his tweets
not because of any cognitive issues
whatsoever now they're completely
ignoring this and it's sad
we're being tested just like you said
every day we're being tested whether
it's iran or
china or hamas or you know or russia
whatever it is we're being tested on the
on the on the national
global stage every single day and he's
failing miserably
and it really is at this point we've got
to figure out what's going on i feel
i feel bad sean because the white house
has been transformed
from a symbol of power and authority
into what looks like at this particular
point an assisted living facility
and the american people are that they
are
they're going to start demanding at some
point in the very near future that we
know what's going on it's already
starting to happen and we need to know
57 percent doctor think that somebody
else is in charge in the white house
including 58
of independents and a third of democrats
think
that he's not making the decisions uh
how does a how does a country function
if the president's incapable of
performing his duties
that's what the poll says my personal
poll
everybody i talk to talks about it
yeah well sean we can't we can't
function i mean we're spending money
like it's going out of style right now
we at least need to know that our
commander-in-chief our head of state
and our president knows what's going on
in that regard and then
on a world stage we're failing miserably
he's not inspiring confidence in the
american people he's not inspiring
confidence in our allies
and he's sending the absolute wrong
message to our adversaries our
adversaries are taking advantage of us
we draw a line in the sand
he they cross the line he draws another
line they cross the line
that did not happen in the trump
administration when president trump drew
a line in the sand
our enemies and our adversaries knew
they knew they knew exactly what would
happen if they crossed that line and we
don't have that anymore we're going to
we're going to pay a price for it
you know a congressman nunes the
geopolitical
territorial ambitions of china seem to
seem to be at no end here we see what
they're outlining
plans for taiwan we've seen the
crackdown in hong kong
we see that they've partnered with the
russians to arm the
iranians so they can fight their proxy
wars in the middle east that's a
dangerous trifecta in my mind
as you look at these now and then now
joe grants
a waiver for putin to build the pipeline
while simultaneously canceling
our pipeline in the keystone xl pipeline
can you explain any of this and
and how nervous are you as a member of
the house intel committee
well i think i can explain it sean the
way that i look at this is
is that you have the pravda style media
in this country that the democrats
control
and then you run that through a filter
which are the social media companies
and it makes it easy to govern as long
as you're doing it in the united states
so you run a campaign you hide in your
basement you don't answer any tough
questions
the same thing happens here in the
united states he's been snapping
at his own press people that they
control and
that's even when they're giving him
cards to try to tell him how to answer
certain questions
but here's the problem putin
knows exactly how this works he's a
former kgb guy he runs
his press in his country the saying
would pres the same thing with president
xi
he does the same thing with the chinese
communist party propaganda that's all
throughout the globe
so when he sits down with these people
they
laugh at him because they know his
cognitive decline
they're probably some of the only people
that get to sit one-on-one with him like
putin got to for an hour or two
you know very few members of congress
have even even sat down with him for any
length of time so i guess the way i
would explain it is is that
when you get out to the real world where
people will
kill others they will take over
companies they will
they will take over economies things get
real
let me take it just let me take this
question
if 57 of the american people in this
trafalgar poll robert haley is a great
pollster
if the 57 percent don't think he's in
charge
and then you add to the equation that
social media is not showing
the video clips that we just showed and
that we've been
showing i would argue that the number
would be dramatically
higher except you have big tech and the
media mob
not showing their audiences what's
really going on when the struggles he's
really having
they're protecting him that no that is
exactly right and that's why i keep
bringing
the attention of the american people to
how big tech is really the big
the biggest danger to our democracy
right now is not only the private media
but it's also coupled with big tech
and a lot of people think republicans
are going to have a great year next year
and i i think we are we're recruiting
candidates across the country
we're doing a great job we're getting
phenomenal people that are standing up
to run like dr jackson
did in the last in the last congress and
last campaign
but you're right i think if the social
media companies weren't covering up
biden tripping
going up air force one uh his the
whispering thing congresswoman
you're being unfair the wind blew them
over not once not twice three times
that's what they said it was a very
windy day
yeah yeah but then also explain
the strange whispering deal the strange
whispering thing if if donald trump
or i did that i mean or if you did that
we'd be mocked from now to the end of
time it would be like the old uh
the old misspelling of potato with vice
president dan quayle it would never end
what what do you what do you mean by
that yeah very strange indeed
uh and uh it's i'm serious i'm i'm not
gonna call him sippy cup anymore
because it's i honestly i'm very worried
this is not a joke anymore
congressman jackson thank you
congressman devin nunes thank you now
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else